[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as always among them these a
woman who combines two very different
niches on Tick Tock and they don't seem
like they go together but they do bring
a lot of people that good feeling of
nostalgia want to take a guess we'll get
into it another woman has a very unique
hobby that hobby standing on the side of
the road so how does she bring people
Joy we'll explain also a man in Fort
Myers Florida he wakes up every day very
early to cook for people who need it
most
and meet a comedian with Good Fortune
you might say that is Fortune feemster
who is sure to put a smile on your face
plus of course our heartwarming videos
ones you just gotta see you're watching
The Uplift
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the uplift the show that
lifts you up for at least the next 30
minutes hopefully longer you and me both
I'm Toyota we're going to start with a
woman who has a very unusual hobby that
combines two very different niches
Caitlin O'Kane has our story there are
many sides to tick tock from True Crime
to dancing to cooking and some Tick Tock
pages are quirky like Rosie grants an
intersection of baking and graveyards it
started out as an assignment for grad
school make a tick tock account from
scratch Rosie decided she was going to
make the recipes people choose for their
gravestones and ended up there's a huge
audience for uh grave talk and Cemetery
Tick Tock I came across this gravestone
for Naomi Miller Dawson and it was it's
beautiful it's like an open book and I
tried it out I posted it on Tick Tock
and it kind of exploded in a very
surprising way
um so then I found more and just kept
doing it now people send her family
recipes
etched in stone and she gets to work in
her kitchen she's made 17 so far and no
matter what the recipe is it gets people
talking like a lot of the comments that
I'll get is people just being like what
would I put on there like it's just like
what's their food of choice like some
people have been like mac and cheese
other kind of people have been like Taco
Bells Crunchwrap Supreme it's endlessly
fascinating and like all the recipes
have been very different like it's not
like oh everyone has like a cheesecake
recipe like every single grave has been
a little bit different from each other
it's so cool
even though gravestones seem like a
morbid Niche Rosie's videos offer
something sweet it's like this insane
like the niche of cemetery Tick Tock and
the niche of uh like food and baking
talk the two things that we inevitably
do in life is we eat food and then we
die someday and it's like this weird
shared experience so I feel like if
anything like that's been the most
interesting comments to me of people
either reflecting on like this is how I
want to be remembered even like yeah I'm
now thinking about my grandparent and
this is what they made every day and
like whenever I make that I think about
them I have like no language for how
interesting and amazing it's been just
to like watch how other people kind of
connect with these topics it's a recipe
for honoring those who passed by
bringing comfort and comfort food to
those in the present
during the pandemic Brenda mcpheeters
found a simple way to spread Joy by
standing on the side of the road CBS
Boston's Katrina Kincaid has more
that's right you get Rocket have a great
weekend God bless you to seed the people
need to hear yeah and and I'm doing it
not in your face well I guess I am doing
it in your face because I'm out here
with the sign hi to many people in
Beverly Brenda mcpheeters needs no
introduction and I know people's names
now kids names dog's names kick hey I
know you since the beginning of the
pandemic she's been standing outside
McPherson Drive in Beverly greeting
people in the mornings with her cheers
dancing and as of a few months ago her
sign some people I had you know you
gotta work at them
like I said woman smiled after two years
took her two years but she did it she
told us she felt a calling one day to
come out and brighten people's mornings
surprise hey you can smile sir there you
go it's okay
you can do it when she started her
father was dying and she got the idea to
include the sign after she would stand
outside the hospital with a sign for him
but she says this isn't about her but
the message she can bring to others life
can be I won't say the word so you know
what if I can just sort of interrupt
your life which is going that way hey
smile she's okay if people don't wave or
honk or even smile back you're a hard
one to crack we'll get you soon sir at
60 and semi retired due to health issues
she says this is how she engages with
people you don't have money to pay for
your mortgage or whatever it may be so I
come along and I'm a goofball and it's
like oh look at smile because she'll be
out here no matter the weather waiting
for a smile one day you know you got to
be patient with people God's patient
with us that's what I say
self-described goofball but she's doing
some good there all right to our next
story which takes us inside a unique Art
Exhibit years in the making here CBS
Minnesota's Adam duckster
inside Elliott Park's gamut Gallery it's
been amazing just the energy that the
artwork brings into this space feels
different than our typical exhibits
co-owner Cassie Garner couldn't be
happier with how the latest display is
shaping off you know you go to art
school and you learn what not to do and
I feel within this exhibit all of that
is thrown out the window and art is just
Art For Art's Sake corporates paper
plastic found objects tape kind of you
name it artist Derek Meyer not only
contributed to the display known as
co-action he curated it every piece seen
here the result of a skilled art teacher
working in tandem with artists with
disabilities all through St Paul's
interact Art Studio there's a lot of
marginalization that exists in all
facets of life when you have a
disability label or need support in in
accessing any Community efforts
um so much of what the work we do is is
just like increased visibility for our
artists make sure they're supported in
all the ways they need to be actual
making of this piece instructor Jeremy
Jones helped shape this piece alongside
artist Kramer hagenbarth I think art is
just a really potent Catalyst that um
unites people of all walks of life it's
cool to see it living you know on the
pedestal where it's supposed to be
getting to this point hasn't been easy
delays with kovid mean the co-action
exhibit is four years plus in the making
this is the medical store now well worth
it it's visibility for interact it's
visibility for the artist it's
visibility for the staff and it's also
just as I mentioned too to put everybody
on the same platform
coming up a former foster kid now all
grown up and using food to help others
also Fortune fiendster talks about
finding herself and becoming the star
she is
[Music]
hey there welcome back to the uplift
time now for those heartwarming videos
ones you just gotta see and we are going
to start with a dog named taco who gets
very excited Every Morning has to be the
one to wake up baby venora look at that
tail wagon uh oh the owner opens the
door and in goes Taco it's an adorable
video and this is a daily occurrence in
that household it went viral of course
shows how strong that Bond can be
between dog and baby
three
all right we got another video and
another dog gone good story you might
say this is a video taken at a dog
adoption the video is taken by a woman
named Leticia who said she didn't know
what to expect when she showed up on
this day uh she had found this
organization called Help rescue Arkansas
and all they told her was a location
where they would be dropping off dogs
for people to take and when she got
there she saw this incredibly long line
of people there waiting to meet their
Furry Friends adopting them so many of
those rescue dogs needed to go home and
find Forever families and so many of
them did Leticia by the way got her own
dog named it Bruno
love that name
all right Sean Penn has been a big
supporter of the country of Ukraine
during its war with Russia and during a
recent visit he met up with Ukrainian
president zielinski and he did this he
gave him an Oscar
here's what he told Ukraine's president
this is for you no Sean yes please that
is yours no I I feel terrible outside I
just thought it's just a symbolic silly
thing yes but I if I know but if I know
this is here with you then I'll then
I'll feel better and stronger for the
fight so great great to honor but yeah
until we will when you when you win
bring it back to Malibu grad yes okay
because I'll feel much better knowing
there's a piece of me here
and of course president zielinski knows
exactly what that is it's an Oscar
zlinski used to be an actor before he
was president think about that he went
from actor to president to Leading his
country in Wartime and Penn said it was
his gift since he's not doing any movies
anymore uh and it's just a little
symbolic thing I think it means a lot
though uh nice job Sean Penn all right
coming up
how is a Wildcat Sanctuary in Minnesota
hoping to do its part all the way over
in Ukraine we'll show you
[Music]
plus meet the former foster kid
dedicating his life now to helping
others now he's found himself giving to
even more people in need free food like
that sign
foreign
cat sanctuary Minnesota has helped more
than a hundred big cats and Counting now
the volunteers have their sights set on
helping cats in Ukraine here CBS
Minnesota's Adam duckster
across the sprawling 40 acres of the
Wildcat Sanctuary 120 big cats lions
tigers and more have a second chance be
nice to your sister be nice that's a
cheap shot like white lions Alana and
Aurora taking in animals like these is
exactly what the Wildcat Sanctuary does
no matter where they're coming from
these two came from Tiger King Park in
Oklahoma back in May of 2021 but
potentially their newest rescues would
come from across the world I can't
believe that when their communities are
crumbling when they don't have power
they don't have phones or anything that
they're still dedicated to getting these
animals to safety when they're going
through so much Wildcat Sanctuary
founder Tammy fees has spent the last
month and a half working with the
International Federation of Animal
Welfare to not only rescue these lion
cubs but get them through customs
permits in the applications it would
take to get them on a plane to the U.S
should they get here they'd spend their
entire entire lives realistically the
next 20 years or so being cared for it's
bittersweet because we shouldn't be
rescuing animals that are born in
captivity be sold and traded these
animals should be growing up wild Thief
says the ongoing war in Ukraine provides
setbacks and challenges but also
perspective four lion cubs might mean it
seemed really small in the scale of the
war but the amount of network we've put
together to help more animals and people
that can support each other is amazing
And for those four Cubs that's a whole
new world and a new life they're going
to have and that means the world
compliance is that the way to refer to
that all right moving on for now Florida
man has dedicated his life to feeding
foster kids and now he finds himself
expanding that Circle of help to others
here's Manuel bojorkas
where are we at on potatoes every
morning
Doug Miller and his staff get cooking a
cooked tortilla makes all the difference
in the world the restaurant is called FK
your diet but before you get the wrong
idea the FK stands for foster kids who
Miller supports I was a foster kid
growing up but his mission has greatly
expanded due to Hurricane Ian and the
thousands left with very little they
don't have the ability to just go out
and buy a new stove or a new
refrigerator a lot of them the place
they worked got damaged so they're not
getting a paycheck all right so the food
here is free and for those who can't get
here Miller delivers okay doing okay I'm
doing okay thank you 125
000 meals so far his girlfriend Amy
Eldridge distributes donated supplies we
can't personally fix what they've lost
but we can bring some comfort to their
day so that's our hope comfort that
Aranda Cruz Garcia says keeps her going
even though in your saddest moments he's
here for you all right love you how many
you got dad a former foster kid now
fostering an entire community
food is love all right coming up do you
need some good fortune we got some
comedian Fortune feemster talks to about
her new Netflix special and how she
found herself in an interview
guaranteed to make you laugh I guarantee
it do stick around
[Music]
thank you
Fortune fiendster is a comedian who
combines self-deprecation with
self-discovery and she sat down with our
Dana Jacobson to talk about her rise to
fame and her current special
is guaranteed to put a smile on your
face
I remember a lot of laughs happened here
but this is where it all started the
Groundlings may be Where it All Began
for Fortune feemster hey kids I'm
Richard Simmons and I love you but she
didn't come here looking for laughs
[Applause]
broke I had no friends in LA and heard
about these classes and thought well
maybe I could meet some friends that way
and so I literally started comedy just
to make friends not let me go to a bar
let me go hang out somewhere no go to an
improv class I was almost late catching
my plane because I was teaching a yoga
class
he's like that did not happen
sters comedy is now winning over
audiences with a relatable style that's
one part self-deprecation one part
self-discovery now I was considered to
be a tomboy back then which was a more
appropriate term for future lesbian her
first Netflix special took us from
Awkward childhood to coming out as an
adult and I say out loud for the first
time in my entire life I go oh my God
I'm gay
all right
I found out I have zero survival skills
none for latest Good Fortune continues
that personal Journey all I had to do
was stay home I got nothing accomplished
no sourdough was started in my house
that's been fun showing people a whole
other side of me who I am as as more of
a fully formed adults or trying to be
right where we all are yeah sometimes I
get it right and sometimes I don't but
again that's the fun part of the journey
themester grew up in Belmont North
Carolina just outside Charlotte as Emily
Fortune feemster it's a name she says
never quite fit her personality did you
know you were funny I knew I had moments
of funny like growing up I would perform
like sketches from Saturday Night Live
like Molly Shannon's Mary Catherine
Gallagher was a big one for me sometimes
when I get nervous yes I stick my hands
under my arms and then I smell my
fingers like that
do you remember thinking at all that
there's a power in that comedy in those
moments I definitely remember
feeling seen for the first time like in
a way that I wasn't seen in a just
everyday life she's she says it was her
grandmother who unknowingly helped plant
the comedy seeds my grandmother was a
very buttoned up woman very
um like that quintessential lady
and then I would watch her watch Carol
Burnett and like belly laugh in a way
that I've not seen before
laughs
and I remember being fascinated that
someone had that ability to do that for
my grandmother and so I I didn't even
realize I was soaking that in not until
those first improv classes I actually
even have a secret talent to pay for
them themester worked as an
entertainment journalist her first job
after moving to Los Angeles
23 year old country bumpkin and this
woman was like do you want to go to Red
Carpet Events and interview celebrities
I'm like uh
I don't know
will there be snacks
that job also provided plenty of Comedy
material and I ended up buying a light
blue velor tracksuit
so the blue velor tracksuit that was
true on the back it had a giant pink
cupcake I have a picture of me I posted
on Instagram interviewing sir in
McKellen in that track oh my God I
didn't know what I was doing just trying
to find my place out here I actually got
approached by a swinger couple after a
show and her place in comedy this is
just a fact of the story they both had
canes
so this was not their first rodeo
it's one medium that you can't fake so I
just had to put the work in and it took
a long time but then uh once it finally
clicks and you start getting to that
point where the audience is connecting
with you and your materials working
there is no better feeling oh hard no
right there wow my goal is always to
make people feel better leaving than
when they got there and some represented
the way themester says she didn't always
feel I think about it from my
perspective and growing up and not
seeing someone like me on television and
not finding someone I could relate to
and I think my journey might have been
different had I seen that I think maybe
I would have come out sooner it is
something that's very powerful when you
see yourself
represented in television be it me as a
southerner me as a bigger girl me as uh
you know gay person it's our two-year
anniversary and we're spending it with
you wow I feel honored or even as a
married couple she and wife Jax wed near
this stretch of beach in Malibu two
years ago there's been little down time
since feemster's latest project just
wrapped in Toronto her most unexpected
to date an action series with Arnold
Schwarzenegger I thought you know I
would be the computer person like not
the active person at all but they're
like no you're a CIA agent and you'll be
out in the field doing the action stuff
and that's how little I knew about the
action world I said the action stuff
did you do your stunts oh no crazy all
right I'm sorry if you watch Good
Fortune you'll find out I'm tough but
not that tough I am not butch which is
shocking I know because I have these
broad shoulders and my favorite color is
plaid I don't ever want to be like one
thing I feel like all of us have a lot
of different dimensions you know it's
easy to sort of put me in a box and I
like to you know peek out of there and
and do some different things that would
surprise people
guaranteed to make you smile as I said
that is our show also guaranteed to make
you smile hope it wasn't a swing and a
miss hope it brightens your day I'm
gonna go find some more good news and
run the bases
[Music]
thank you